forty finalists 20 winners $100,000 to
drop out of school and pursue our dreams
I'm Lucy and Justine technorati we are
picking 20 people I find it sad that we
you know have to cap ourselves somewhere
but I guess we do Hey I love the new
blue thank you I've always wanted to
have blue hair and then I figured why
not right now I think it's beautiful
that the foundation has collected such
an incredible encyclopedia of living
people that will make a difference in
the world I'm doing pretty good at her
you guys whether or not I get the
fellowship I'm gonna continue to push
this project forward I want to leave a
legacy I remember someone that came up
with a solution
that never existed before to a prom
that's always been there the first
question is we'd like to invite you into
the fellowship I'm in that sounds
awesome now that they've been selected
over the summer we help them with
housing in the Bay Area a hundred
percent I could not win to be out there
oh my god how do you think your parents
are gonna feel about this I suppose that
my mother when she heard that I wasn't
going to grad school became very worried
that I would you know never become a
rock star so I think that she will feel
safe that I am now associated with an
institution formerly fellows are always
welcome to go back to school once they
finish their fellowship and we have seen
that a small handful have gone back to
school well they're not happy but I kind
of hung up on me
I think that in your youth it's the best
time in your life to just take risks
like go out and try new things
be a kid or don't be a kid drop out of
college go pursue your dreams because
that's really the only time in your life
you're going to have the freedom to do
so my answer is yes don't worry I'm
going to have a lot of things planned
I'm gonna text my mom right now promise
it's exciting to me that I now have the
mentors and maybe I need to advance my
project in a more efficient manner and
now that I have the freedom to learn and
do that's just really really exciting to
me in 10 years I see myself continuing
to frolic about in the combination of
computer science physics and math and
continuing to develop assistive
technology to help people in need it's
probably the big biggest achievement
done so far but hopefully at one point I
can add to it saving millions of lives I
don't put my life where it could just go
one of two ways in they're both great
but so opposite directions and I super
excited you have idea you just
absolutely change my life this is what
success feels like I am exactly where I
need to be right now no matter what you
want to do if you work hard enough at it
there's literally always a way to pull
it off I want to change the world
it's been an incredible journey but
there are more challenges ahead do we
have what it takes to push forward with
our projects in the real world subscribe
to the wire channel for more team
Technorati
[Music]